well Tampa police are holding a suspect
this morning in the hunt for a suspected
serial killer Howell Emanuel Donaldson
known as Trey is charged with four
counts of first degree murder and what
Bork is is at the scene where Donaldson
was found and well good morning good
morning police believe Trey Donaldson
works or previously worked at this
McDonald's over the past two months
they've received more than five-thousand
tips in this case but it was a tip
yesterday afternoon from an employee of
this fast-food restaurant that led to
the 24 year olds arrest tonight we're
bringing someone to justice who doesn't
deserve the right to walk amongst us
nearly two months after the first
killing in Seminole Heights Tampa police
swarmed this McDonald's in Ybor City to
arrest Trey Donaldson Gayle Rogers says
she worked with the suspect at
McDonald's
he wasn't like us he was like a family a
real family we fight yeah we have fun
you say something to him he didn't like
he just like a different person the
string of murders has left the Seminole
Heights neighborhood on edge for weeks
the four victims were all killed within
a few blocks of each other while walking
alone according to the police affidavit
positional data pulled from Donaldson's
phone placed him near those locations
around the times of the murders the
affidavit also states clothing recovered
from his vehicle is similar to clothing
seen in the surveillance videos
Donaldson is from the tampa area but
also has connections to New York the
NYPD confirms he was arrested in
Manhattan in 2014 but would not say for
what he also attended st. John's
University in Queens
Tampa mayor Bob Buckhorn said the arrest
will hopefully bring justice 51 days ago
I said this was a struggle between good
and evil well tonight goodness is one
Police listed a 40 caliber Smith &
Wesson handgun in Donaldson's Jail
records now according to an affidavit
that would match the casings found at
the scene of the first three murders
also the affidavit states that he
purchased a box of Smith & Wesson
ammunition on October 7th that's just
two days before the first murder Gale
all right man well thank you very much